[Music]
and even traveling all over the place
recently haven't you yeah I've been
doing a bit of a little bit of a world
tour doing stand-up I've seen you do
stand-up
obviously I've seen you as special
you're very funny doing stand-up where
have you been it was the most
interesting recent um well I just did
the whole of Scandinavia just before
Christmas which is nice very slowly and
snowy very festive
you know I'm huge in Finland I'm a big
big star in Finland are you ready yes
what do you mean are you really it's
probably I don't know why you'd be
sceptical why doesn't why you'd be here
if you're a big star in Finland it's
only good for about a day or two and
then they won't they want me to move it
along yeah but but we're we're about to
worry did them Norway and Sweden playing
these huge mega domes it was it was
amazing because there's there's no
language barrier they speak English it's
it's bizarre you know it's crazy they
speak they speak English they speak it
very well perfect English absolutely
perfect English yeah and it was it was
fun do you talk about their culture at
all I mean I would think that comedy I
do the same stuff wherever I go when
you're dealing with things like Hitler
and famine is pretty universal so those
are always nice family be city old on
wanking jacking off more like you know
but you know I did I started off with
talking about that I was in Scandinavia
so I told him they were descended from
Vikings rapists finally start off with
your best stuff yeah so were there in
front of all these people here saying
you're all descended from Vikings who
are I said I forgave them for all the
raping and pillaging but how'd that go
over it was good they they I mean they
admitted that the pillaging was
secondary to the raping that's what
they're that's what they came over for
they've got the raping hats on the
Vikings getting off a boat and he's
running toward you there's only one
thing on his mind if he's wearing that
hat okay is so silly you would talk
about them and these what you would call
in your words this this rate they didn't
know how they've got away because
obviously it was only the men that went
look they came from like Norway and
Sweden and they came and they raped all
over Europe they raped and everywhere
and I was just I just considered that
that guy you know saying to his wife
going on I'm off for gonna see some of
the rest of Europe all right you have a
nice time what why are you taking your
raping hat will just leave it here well
the other guys are taking their
so ya know it was a long time ago we
laughed about it yeah yeah yeah
thousands of years ago